The joe rogan experience.
You get two of you together and you're like,
let's go eat some coyote and see what it tastes like.
Yeah,
well I'm going to have to eat one spin sneaking around my yard.
They're trying to figure out how to get to my chickens.
Sneaky Fox.
It's so weird.
Oh,
I know they will.
He's fucking creeps.
I was in my,
uh,
I was in my yard.
I'll just about to let the chickens out and I see this motherfucker looking
through the fence,
just looking right at me and looking at the chickens and like,
Whoa,
that's kind of creepy.
It's like you have imagined having a friend and you know that the friend is
safe,
but right outside the door you could see a guy wants to kill your friend and
he's just trying to figure out a way to get in.
That's what it was.
He's going to get in and kill your friend with his face and his chickens are
like my little friends,
you know,
they,
they lay eggs.
I say hello girls.
You know,
I feed them.
They,
they bucking,
they come near you when the,
you know,
when you come out and this conti fucking dog,
once they eat my friends,
I had a,
we had some chickens,
you know,
we're deciding,
okay,
we're going to let them free cause they gotta they gotta get out and they got a
pack and they got to get some bugs and they're just happier.
So we let the chickens out.
Well,
I didn't know their neighbor had a rooster.
The rooster comes over,
right.
He just claims my chickens.
And so you'd go out to feed the chickens.
The rooster would come attack you.
I mean,
he would just get up there,
spur your legs,
everything.
Yeah.
So I mean,
this is crazy rooster and we could not keep him away from the chickens.
I mean,
he's raping my ladies.
I want,
my goal was the unfertilized chicken eggs in a lot of balloons.
So we're trying to think like,
we can't kill this dude's rooster.
I mean,
that's just not right.
So I got this concrete rooster and I put it out by the chicken coop.
That rooster comes over and just starts fighting this concrete rooster.
He kicked his own ass and just left,
came back.
So if you have rooster problems,
man,
just,
just get a statue.
That's his own ass.
That's amazing.
What a dumb fucking animal.
He was like scared to come down,
right?
Stupid.
Everything's good.
Joe,
you a real comedian.
Dom Merera you just saying that for folks who didn't listen to the commercial
part,
you don't have a tool.
You know you'd ever done a thing.
He never turned a wrench.
There's two bucks.
There's two toolboxes and warehouse and they would have left two women that live
with me that I had a broad tool boxes.
I can't even lift it.
It was one of the key lift.
I don't know how Sophie lifted it.
That's hilarious.
Every time somebody shakes my hand,
they go,
man,
you don't have soft hands.
All the butter,
the leg butter smooth.
Yeah.
That's uh,
that's,
I really feel believed that there's a real,
there's a real factor in that you've remaining on top of your game all these
years.
Like you surely you truly like completely.
You know,
you're a comedian.
That's it.
That's what you're capable of.
I love it.
I could do it in a hammock.
I followed crystal Leah the other night at the,
he did a standing ovation and lift factor,
right.
I walk in and this was true.
I had just woken up.
I took a nap like at nine o'clock at night and the audience was standing.
I got it now.
I said,
first of all,
it's Chris just got a standing ovation.
I just woke up.
I said,
uh,
I was just in the bath tub like a big fat fag.
So Lazy.
The only reason I was taking a birth coach,
too lazy to stand up and shape.
Right.
And I said that a crown.
Then what would you do if you were me?
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
Fly around the room,
you know?
What do you mean after he,
yesterday,
after we had a standing ovation and am I supposed to fly around the room as it
now?
Tell me what to do.
And then you know,
they were with me because it was honest,
you know?
But the thing is,
what of what you were saying about just I,
I give a fuck totally,
but I don't give a fuck.
Like I could do it in a hammock at this point.
Just be,
let's just my head out doing stand.
That's actually not a bad idea.
That be pretty funny for 10 to be a good act.
You were just laying there,
especially like if you,
it was a part of like a comedy festival,
not even a regular set.
Just like ladies and gentlemen,
we present you dom Irrera and a hammock and you just swinging back and forth
with a wireless microphone in the air and talking shit.
When you look at the Warren Commission report and you look at the
inconsistencies in it,
there's a great book about it called the best evidence by David Liftin,
who was,
um,
he was actually an accountant and was hired to go over the Warren Commission
report and found inconsistency after inconsistency over and over again.
A detailed these in great order,
but dif difference in the inconsistency of the autopsies and consistencies of
the various reports of what went down in consistencies in the Warren Commission
of their findings that would cancel out each other's findings.
He was in one of the few guys with the first guys to go through the entire 900
volumes.
Fascinating,
fascinating book that I read when I was living in New Jersey.
I was a,
it was living in New York rather,
and I was doing a Gig on the road and I read it and fucking bombed that night.
All my God,
it was in my hotel room all day reading is freaky conspiracy books shitting my
pants and I was like 23 years old and then I went on stage that night and just,
I hate it.
It's terrible.
And I,
I learned a very valuable lesson from that book.
Don't read or watch depressing shit right before you go onstage or break into
big conspiracy mongering in the middle of your set that you just know.
No,
but I became a conspiracies break for sure.
For sure.
That book best evidence was what threw me over the top.
I've had to really distinctive times where the things that I saw on before I
went onstage fucked me up.
That was a big one.
That was probably the first one.
Might have been the second one.
It was all the same time.
It was a slow learner,
but the other one was a,
I went with uh,
um,
uh,
this guy named JB smooth,
you know,
JB smooth,
funny fucks.
He's hilarious.
And Jb and I were doing a college together in New Jersey and a JB was a,
it was really hard to find.
And J B,
uh,
was,
he was running late,
so they had me go on first.
And I wasn't prepared because I was sitting in the Er there.
They had a little rec room with a TV on and the TV was showing this documentary
on the Malibu fires.
Uh,
it was so fucking depressing.
It was the early nineties,
and these people lost everything.
And this guy was crimes,
a fireman and he was crying and wheat and his house was still there,
but his neighbors had lost their houses.
And he was just crying,
weeping.
This girl was looking for her dog.
And they like,
all right,
Joe,
I'm JB is still late.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna put you on and you do your sat and then
he'll go on after you.
I was like,
oh no.
So I went on stage thinking about this guy crying,
not even for his own loss,
but for his neighbors loss.
And that girl looking for a dog.
And I just got so sad and I went on stage at age shit when I was in high school.
Uh,
I don't remember the kid's name,
but someone wrote a really cool article,
uh,
one of the,
one of the kids in my school,
uh,
about boy scouts,
about the problem with the whole,
uh,
the code of the boy scouts because one of them was keeping your thoughts clean.
Those that,
right.
Yeah.
I forget the exact,
let's,
let's put a boy scout code.
So you get to thinking about something and you're like,
man,
I shouldn't be thinking about that.
Well,
this guy was,
uh,
the guy who wrote this.
I remember reading this as I was,
uh,
you know,
a high school student going,
this guy's got a really good fucking point.
The point was like,
what do you give a fuck?
What I think like why are you trying to control my thoughts?
Like I'm not hurting anybody.
I might think something crazy and deviant,
but I'm not doing it if as long as I'm not doing it.
Oh,
why am I supposed to keep my thoughts pure?
Maybe it's fun for me to entertain ridiculous thoughts.
I know.
Cause that's Kinda like what self control is.
Like self control doesn't speak to that thought.
The idea is you entertain SelfControl speaks to or it's like you get an email
and you're like,
I'm going to write a really mean email back.
But,
and then you,
it's so fun to imagine what you're saying to me.
An email,
I'm to put it up,
it's Molly.
Like you write a regular email and that is like supposed to be like adult
behavior.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Control.
And we'll,
you know,
someone's willing to sold trolling your actions.
You see someone who's an asshole on the car and you want to pull them out of the
car and beat him to death,
but you don't,
you don't do anything.
You just go,
you drive down.
Yeah.
I would,
I would pull his fingernails out
so his eyes open and throw salt in them and make them stare at the sun.
I never go there.
I just go to bone breaking right away.
Snap someone's arm.
They don't want to fight back.
Um,
yeah.
Trustworthy,
loyal,
helpful,
friendly,
courteous,
kind,
obedient,
cheerful,
thrifty.
Brave,
clean.
Reverent.
A scout is reverend towards God.
He's faithful in his religious duties.
He respects the belief of others.
Yeah.
Here's the big one.
Clean a scout,
keeps his body and mind fit in.
Clean.
That was the one that this guy had a problem with.
I remember reading that and going,
yeah,
the fucking,
the boy scouts are silly.
It's kids.
Right?
Okay.